bei mir geht s recht bündig um unser
verhältnis zur ukraine wenn ich von uns
spreche spreche natürlich von den
deutschen die eine sehr merkwürdige
politik gefahren haben die beste zeit
die letzten jahre wir haben ja die
warnungen der ukraine dass ein
russischer angriffskrieg bevorsteht sehr
lange ignoriert und dann haben wir seit
2014 der ukraine den beitritt zu nato
die ganze zeit verweigert obwohl die
krise schon genommen wurde dort donners
besetzt war putin hat allerdings nie ein
geheimnis daraus gemacht dass er die
ukraine als ein russlands ansieht für
ihn ist die ukraine gar kein staat und
sie hat für ihn gar keine eigene
geschichte deswegen frage ich mich wieso
haben wir diese warnung der ukraine
ignoriert und meine antwort jedenfalls
ist es deutschland einfach das banale
interesse hat mit russland geschäfte zu
machen das sehen wir nicht nur an
solchen putin lobbyisten wie schröder
ist ja ein bisschen billig jetzt einfach
nur auf ihnen zu zeigen das ist auch die
politik der letzten 16 jahre merkel die
verschiedenen kabinette die wir hatten
ich möchte mal zwei beispiele nennen wir
erinnern uns sehr gut an den früheren
außenminister heiko maas der hat auf der
uno-vollversammlung donald trump
ausgelacht was der darauf hingewiesen
hat dass deutschland sich durch nord
stream 2 nur noch weiter in die
abhängigkeit von russland rein steigert
ich möchte außerdem olaf scholz nennen
der heute als bundeskanzler von einer
zeitenwende spricht der war noch bis vor
kurzem unser finanzminister und in
dieser funktion hatte alles versucht um
jetzt schon 2 durchzusetzen
auch gegen den widerstand der usa um
nicht missverstanden zu werden ich finde
es sehr gut dass wir der ukraine waffen
liefern und dass wir die ukraine in die
eu aufnehmen wollen auch dass wir
russland für diesen krieg sanktionieren
aber ich finde das reicht nicht denn
wenn wir in zukunft eine bessere
deutsche außenpolitik wollen müssen wir
alle diese versäumnisse auf arbeiten
sonst wiederholen wir die fehler aus der
vergangenheit darf ich mit einem
geständnis antworten ich habe keine
geschäfte mit russland gemacht auch
nicht mit der ukraine aber dennoch
gehöre ich zu denen die nicht reagiert
haben warum weil ich mir gar nicht
vorstellen konnte dass putin so dumm ist
diesen krieg anzufangen er macht
überhaupt aus meiner sicht überhaupt
keinen sinn für russland außer dass er
das land erobern bild das sich das
einverleiben will es ist eine so
schreckliche geschäft wird ihm auch nie
gelingen die ukraine zu unterwerfen da
wird es immer widerstand geben angriffe
auf us-soldaten usw das war für mich
völlig außerhalb meiner gedankenwelt
aber wir lernen eben jetzt ich frage
mich war putin schon immer so oder ist
auch so geworden da habe ich noch keine
schlüssige antwort darauf gehört
möglicherweise ist er erst so geworden
aber das spielt jetzt auch keine rolle
mehr für den jetzigen zustand
er führt diesen krieg der keinen sinn
macht und
er ist ein aus meiner sicht heute ein
durchgeknallter groß russischer despot
der nicht mehr zu kalkulieren ist und
mit dem man auch glaube ich kein
friedensvertrag schließen kann ich
glaube das nicht ich sage nochmal ich
sag's immer wieder der muss gestürzt
werden ich halte das auch nicht für
realistisch dass putin jetzt auf einmal
einlenkt es ist ja so dass dieser krieg
wirklich ist auch strategisch nur dann
sinn ergeben hätte wenn
putins vorstellung die ukraine ergeben
sich sofort sie empfangen die russen als
befreit werden wenn das eingetreten wäre
dann hätte russland sagen können wir
haben den krieg gewonnen ohne große
kosten ohne große opfer aber jeder der
irgendwie mal in der ukraine war oder
mit ihnen gesprochen hat weiß dass das
nicht der fall ist dass die ukraine ein
ein freies land sein sein wollen dass
die nicht unter russischer besatzung
leben wollen
vielleicht lohnt es sich dann sich zu
fragen ja was was diese motive für den
krieg sind und sich einfach mal
anzuschauen was putin selber gesagt hat
schon nicht erst seit letztem jahr
ich hab's ja vorhin erwähnt er hat eine
sehr merkwürdige geschichtsauffassung
beispielsweise ich meine jeder der der
sich mal mit einem ukraine und hält mit
einem russen unterhält in ihren
jeweiligen sprachen merkt dass es
verschiedene sprachen sind verschiedene
kulturen die zwar ähnliche wurzeln haben
aber sich auseinanderentwickelt haben
und wer ernsthaft heute noch im 21
jahrhundert denkt dass es alles in eine
art neues zarenreich gehört der hat
wirklich nicht mehr alle tassen im
schrank und die fehler die fehler haben
mit lenin begonnen